-Congrats on everything.
I want to get into everything.
"Funny Girl."
-Okay, let's go.
-I want to get into everything,
but first,
this is such a cool story,
from what I heard.
The last time you were hear,
it was with Jonathan Groff.
-Right.
-And you sang a song.
-Yep.
-Thank you so much for that.
-I appreciate it always,
seeing you.
Through the years,
you've been great to us.
-Thank you. No, I was here
in 2019, December, 2019.
And I wanted to tell you,
it was so funny, 'cause
I was singing a song from
my Christmas album
and we were
in the middle of this
little press tour run
that I was doing.
And I turned to Jonathan
and I was like,
"I really don't know if I can go
on to perform at 'Jimmy.'"
I was like, "I don't feel good."
We were walking to the stage
and the floor kept feeling like
it was coming out from
underneath my feet.
And we did, like -- he's like,
"You're probably just nervous."
We did a little champagne toast.
We went out that night.
We had so much fun, and
I woke up the next morning
and I said to my husband, I was
like, "I feel so hungover."
And he was like,
"You didn't drink."
I was like, "I know.
I just don't feel good."
And he was like, "Do you think
you might be pregnant?"
I was like, "No!"
It didn't really seem like
it was in the cards for us.
I was like, "No, there can't --"
He was like,
"You should just check."
And I was! Here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
At the show!
-On our show?
-Yeah!
-You were pregnant on our show!
-I was, and I had no idea.
-And how old is he?
-He's 2.
He just turned 2 in August.
-I have to say hi. Hi, Ever.
Mommy's at work.
I love you so much.
-Oh, my God. That's amazing.
-Yeah. It's been wild.
-Does he love
when you sing to him?
-That's a fun question. Yeah.
-Okay, alright.
Sorry. He doesn't?
-No, I mean --
So this is the first time
I've gone back to work.
I've been home with him
for the past two years 100%,
and now I'm back to work.
So my singing coach was like,
you know, try to incorporate
what you're doing,
like, try to incorporate him
into it
so he can be a part of it
and you can be not away
from him as much.
So I was warming up
the other day
and my husband was like,
"Should we come in?"
I was like, "Yes, come in.
Watch me do my warm up."
And I hit some high note,
and he started
hysterically crying.
[ Laughter ]
Disaster?
-I'm like, okay.
That was a big fail.
-That one's not gonna work.
Well, we tried.
-I tell him all the time,
I'm like,
"What do you want
to hear tonight? Anything.
Do you want Celine?
Do you want Barbara?"
-Taking requests!
-Anything you want.
"Baba? Baba Greengrass."
And I don't know if you've heard
"The Green Grass Grows,"
but that one is just...
It's a real
tough one for parents.
It's just the same thing
over and over.
-Oh, no, no, no.
I'm over that phase
of those songs.
I mean,
if I heard the Backpack song
one more time, from Dora,
I was going to...
-Oh, no, no.
-...find the person
and murder them.
[ Laughter ]
I know they're bringing joy
to people, but I had enough.
-I wake up in the morning...
-It would haunt me, yeah.
-The first thing I hear is,
♪ Peppa Pig ♪
-♪ Peppa Pig ♪ -- Yeah.
-Over and over again.
-I know every single theme song.
-I know every song
on "Daniel Tiger."
Like, I know it all.
-Yeah, yeah, I loved it,
and I'm so happy
I'm done with that phase.
-Well, we are
in the thick of it.
-You are in the thick of it.
-We are in the thick of it.
-Get ready.
Can I just read you
some nice reviews here?
-Oh, my goodness.
-For your performance
in "Funny Girl."
"Lea Michele is a revelation
as Fanny Brice," says 'The Cut.'
"Lea Michele is stupendous.
'Funny Girl' has a missile,
a performer who,
from her first words,
'Hello, gorgeous,'
shoots straight
to her target and hits it.
"The New York Times" said that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
How about this?
"The Washington Post" said,
"Lea Michele doesn't just
bring down the house,
she brings down
the whole darn block."
"Washington Post."
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's how you do it!
That's how you do it.
And my friend went to go
see you opening night,
and I want to six or seven
standing ovations
during the play,
during the song,
mid-song standing ovations.
Buddy, you hit a home
run on this.
-Thank you. It's been so
awesome. It's been great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How does it feel
to be back on Broadway?
-Oh, my God,
that in and of itself
is just so unbelievable.
I'd been wanting to come back
to Broadway for so many years.
I was gone for 15 years.
"Spring Awakening"
was the last show that I did.
[ Light applause ]
-Yeah.
-But to be back... Yay!
To be back
and to be in the show
that I've loved
for so many years.
But I'm such a fan
of this production.
Incredible cast,
this incredible score.
-Can we even just talk about
the "Glee" of it all?
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-I'm getting goosebumps.
I loved you, obviously,
on "Glee."
We've done bits since then.
You've always been great.
I've watched probably 100 times,
you sing "Rain on my Parade."
and I would cry.
I'd go show everyone,
"You want to see the best thing
you've ever seen on television?"
Watch Lea Michele sing this.
Oh my gosh, now you're
doing it on Broadway.
-Now I'm doing it!
-It is like...
-I know, it's really awesome.
It's so fantastic.
I mean, but, you know,
look, I'm 36 now,
and the story of
"Funny Girl" spans
through the course of,
you know, many years.
You see her love
and her loss and her failures
and her successes
and becoming a mom and a wife.
And I feel like at this point,
being where I am right now,
it's just perfect.
Timing is everything,
and I'm so grateful.
-It couldn't
happen to a better person.
-Thank you so much.
-We love you,
and you're performing for us.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I am.
-Lea Michele
is performing for us.
Check out "Funny Girl"
on Broadway.com for tickets.
Lea is performing a song from
"Funny Girl" when we come back.
Stick around!